your voice it is magical town sounds  like Gwen two girls are really like  that's Blake Shelton comparing the voice  hopeful Brittney kennel to his  girlfriend Gwen Stefani this season  Blake decided to mix a little business  with pleasure bringing in his rockstar  gal pal to mentor his competing  contestants and on Tuesday's episode he  made this adorable pledge to her if I  win this season with you as my mentor I  will share the victory with okay  Brittney battled Trey O'Dell on Tuesday  show singing Fleetwood Mac's the chain  and the Montreal natives performance  drew Gwen comparisons yet again Brittney  you have that really fast vibrato  there's someone Gwen Stefani about her  two girlfriends ultimately Blake went  with his gut and picked Brittney who  teared up with excitement over his  decision I can't even put into words it  says means a lot